[Musique]
salut juju salut Casimir tu m'as l'air
de tenir une forme splendide ce matin
ouais j'ai fait ma toilette je sens bon
et j'ai très envie de danser avec toi tu
veux qu'on fasse notre danse aujourd'hui
et alors bah d'accord mais alors
laisse-moi le temps d'aller me changer
d'accord tiens pendant ce temps-là moi
je vais aller chercher ma canne
les enfants les enfants venez venez près
de moi
venez vous asseoir à côté de moi venez
tous viens viens vite à côté de moi vous
allez me rendre un très grand service
bien la viens
viens à côté de moi viens vous savez ce
que c'est qu'un défaut
vous avez tous qu'est-ce que c'est un
défaut tu sais
c'est quelque chose qu'on fait mal quand
on fait mal tu peux me décider des
défauts
je sais pas moi par exemple être avare
c'est un défaut c'est pas un défaut au
travail c'est un défaut un travail après
tu peux m'en citer d'autres de défauts
être voleur très bien ensuite tu connais
des défauts qu'est-ce qu'un
bandit oui d'accord mais par exemple
être méchant très bien la méchanceté
c'est un grand défaut et être menteur
c'est un défaut c'est un grand défaut
être un menteur ensuite l'égoïsme par
exemple c'est pas un défaut très égoïste
très bien et être distrait
vous savez ce que c'est être distrait
oui c'est pas un défaut
vous êtes très gentil vous me rendez un
très grand service bien et ben écoutez
je vous remercie beaucoup les enfants au
revoir à bientôt
les enfants attendez-moi j'ai besoin de
vous venez par ici
pour sûr vous savez que les qualités
c'est le contraire des défauts hein les
qualités le contraire des défauts alors
je voudrais que vous me donniez des des
noms de qualité
alors chercher réfléchissez un petit peu
pardon pas très gentil être gentil ah ça
ça c'est une qualité d'être gentil très
bien et très bien Jean-François
un gentil à toi toi mon grand
[Musique]
et toi
travailleur à la plus belle des qualités
enfin c'est ce que vous dit mon chef
là et toi il y a pas trouvé une qualité
cherche bien allez allez allez
généreux une bonne qualité
je n'ai re 8 voilà à toi
bon
oui oui bien sûr bon ben
[Musique]
d'être obéissant voilà une bonne qualité
ça m'en fait quelques-unes déjà de
qualité voilà
de donner beaucoup d'argent d'être
généreux mais c'est ce qu'on a dit
d'ailleurs déjà tout à l'heure bien et
ben les enfants je vous remercie bien
allez jouer maintenant vous pouvez
continuer il faut que je te parle
moi aussi j'ai des choses à te dire
tiens vous étiez là vous poursuivre le
hasard fait quelques fois bien les
choses
que voulez-vous insinuer monsieur du
snob et bien mon cher ami juste souhaité
que vous êtes sûr que c'est à moi que
vous voulez parler à un contestablement
écoute quasiment
et scientifique sur ton caractère et je
le regrets de te dire que tu n'as que
des défauts
c'était affreux ça
mais non quasiment moi aussi justement
j'ai fait une étude sur ton caractère
curieux hasard pour sûr tu n'as que des
qualités
mais laissez-moi vous donner le résultat
de mon étude qui est elle sérieuse
scientifique
premier défaut la curiosité la curiosité
ben moi je l'ai comme première qualité
la curiosité une qualité que d'aller
regarder écouter tout ce qui ne vous
concerne pas mais la curiosité de
Casimir c'est la soif de s'instruire
c'est d'apprendre plein de choses pour
devenir aussi savant que François
ah alors quoi c'est une qualité ou un
défaut une queue une qualité poursuivre
deuxième défaut
l'obstination
c'est aussi sur ma liste une bien belle
qualité pas vrai
que d'être têtu et de par reconnaître
qu'on vient qu'on vient de faire une
bêtise mais l'obstination de Casimir lui
permet de poursuivre un effort malgré
les embûches et de parvenir au but c'est
c'est sublime bon troisième défaut la
prodigalité et attendez c'est c'est quoi
là on dit gars
la prodigalité est un horrible défaut
que signifie que tu dépenses sans
raisonner tout ce que tu as
pour sur je ne connais pas de plus belle
qualité Casimir quasiment c'est vrai n'a
rien pour oui il le garde rien ils
donnent tout aux autres oui c'est un
être d'une exceptionnelle
bonté merci mon cher ami je constate
avec regret que vous avez choisi à
chaque fois de dire le contraire de ce
que j'affirme ah vraiment monsieur du
club vous me feriez de la peine en
pensant une chose pareille c'est voyons
c'est le hasard si tous les défauts que
vous citez sont sur ma liste des
qualités c'est vraiment fâchées
là quasiment toi tu nous dérange nous
parlons sérieusement
vous êtes quand même en train de parler
de mes qualités de mes défauts ah mais
c'est vrai j'avais complètement oublié
bon ben nous t'écoutons que j'ai mis je
voudrais savoir si quand je danse est-ce
que c'est une qualité ou un défaut
assurément c'est un défaut je ne suis
pas d'accord non danser comme un
casimirus mais c'est une très grande
qualité c'est un défaut une qualité un
défaut une qualité un défaut une qualité
et vous vous disputez il n'arrive pas à
se mettre d'accord pour savoir si danser
comme un casimirus c'est une qualité ou
un défaut mais c'est ça asseyez-vous
tous les deux sur le banc regardez
quasiment danser et vous jugera ensuite
excellent idée très bien j'espère
qu'après cette démonstration mon cher
ami vous conviendrez que j'avais raison
pour sûr après cette danse vous vous
rangerez à mon avis alors attention
musique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors facteur dansez comme un casimirus
c'est une qualité ou un défaut pour sûr
c'est une grande qualité
et pour vous monsieur du snap cher ami
je reste convaincu que c'est un défaut
vous avez raison monsieur du Nord j'en
ai connu des défauts enfin presque car
j'ai au moins une qualité et laquelle et
bien c'est comme moi monsieur je ne suis
pas snob oh